in a world where seeds could easily grow
in your stomach the demand for seedless
fruits and vegetables would Skyrock it
even if it meant the price of produce
would jump because of the extra time it
would take to remove every little seed
people would rather pay more or not at
all for the privilege of not turning
into a fruit
tree this would be a world in which
seeds have adapted to grow much faster
than ever before since it normally takes
several weeks for a seed to germinate
while the stomach digests its food
within a few
hours seeds need warmth moisture and
oxygen to germinate and you'll find all
that in the stomach but you'll also find
hydrochloric acid the hydrochloric acid
would have no trouble dissolving a
seed's protective coating which would
allow the seed to absorb some water and
start to grow the